foreign
Daniel welcome to the show the two to
three p.m Eastern slot where I am going
to unbox I'm gonna unboxer now
that's a big deal Daniel this is awesome
I I'm super excited hello to everyone
who's tuning in Gary great to see you as
well we're here with Damon and Roy as
well
I'm with it I love what you do listen
Gary Masters of the Universe this is big
this is huge like I've seen the
reaction you know I've been busy all day
but I've been trying to kind of poke
into the Discord into Twitter
um but I think you've been on the pulse
and I'm gonna look at uh all the people
Liam Kimmy Gass Harrison Alpha is free
like it seems like a lot of people
especially if they're in the know you
know under 25
you know I can see more and more people
know Masters of the Universe more and
more but man if you're over 35 people
have been losing their mind in
excitement to this and wait till they
see do you guys put up pictures in the
blog post
everything so they got a sense of how
epic this is but I do think up close and
personal in this unboxing it's a whole
different I agree I saw the images and
then I saw it even I haven't even seen
this I'm actually and you saw what I did
right so I gave it to me this and I was
like no no he was like starting to open
I'm like I'm gonna unbox live because I
want my authentic unboxing happening
here so I'm really excited Daniel let's
get everybody set up but also let's say
hello to everybody in the chat because
this is a community thing
obviously if you're people are watching
all over on Instagram Instagram great to
see you but if you're in the Be Friends
Community Tick Tock great to see you
somewhere where is Tick Tock is it just
linked is ticked on not happening you
didn't bring it
[Music]
Tick Tock you're coming
um soon but the be friends who own you
know a bee friend are in our chat right
now through the website on
meet.vfriends.com everybody uh please
check out on Open Season you're about to
find out why
um but we have a really cool unveiling
which will be open to the general public
as well
um so I'm excited about this I have a
feeling people that are collecting toys
which is on the rise are about to see
some super fire in this brown box uh and
I'm excited about that Daniel set us up
amazing yeah let's start from the top
for those that are joining and have no
idea what the heck's going on you're
just tuning in first of all thank you
for taking time out of your day to be
here we're just really excited here at V
friends we're announcing the most latest
partnership with v friends and Mattel
and their legendary IP Universe Masters
of the Universe franchise to deliver an
unbelievable collaboration we are
releasing in partnership with Mattel
Masters of the Universe Origins Skeletor
and V friends
skilled skeleton two pack it's super
exciting it goes on sale October 6th 12
p.m 45 dollar price and it's available
worldwide U.S and international we're
going to drop the links here in the chat
this is massive all of the details of
the countries prices which I know is
super important to our community in
Australia in the UK all over the world
Canada we have all that information on
the Mattel site check out the blog on
blog.vfriends but again massive
collaboration with Masters of the
Universe and Mattel to have this be
friends skilled skeleton and Skeletor
coming together in this unique product
available on Mattel's official website
we're also joined by I'm sorry to
interrupt here and like Maddie n said in
the chat and I think for a lot of people
here I'm looking at Instagram because I
know I'm doing this to meet.bfriends.com
let's call spit of Spain Skeletor
is one of the iconic fictional
characters intellectual property on
Earth and Maddie called it out properly
like wait till you see what I'm about to
show you and for for Motu fans for
Masters of the Universe fans and we've
got the Mattel gang with us they're
going to go into more nerd culture more
Comic-Con culture more masters of
universe culture the form factor of
Skeletor is incredibly imperative in
this toy there's an enormous amount of
He-Man collectors that are going to go
after this toy because of skeletors form
factor that's different than what uh
just a b Friends Community I'm actually
looking I have a ram man somewhere here
oh no well this is yes for all the
people that don't know this is skilled
skeleton
in V friends this is you're going to be
seen very shortly but Skeletor is a g
like a real G and like skeletoric
matters in the culture right like you'll
go in like
a pretty cool hip-hop concert
and see somebody rocking a Skeletor
hoodie like Skeletor is different and
that's why we're so pumped about this
and unlike any other collabo when we did
Mattel with Uno right
you know there's Uno collectors but like
there's a different level of Motu fans
like you Masters and universe fans are
hardcore one of the things that I'm kind
of want to make sure why we did this
event is I want people to
um you know I want people to
know the exact date and time
Daniel because I think a lot of people
in the v Friends Community are going to
get caught off guard that they're going
to be competing with the He-Man Masters
of the Universe collectors once this
becomes and this is like on action and
action figure insider right now it's on
Yahoo News like the the news is
spreading on this collab pretty strong
in the last hour and I think it's gonna
be a little bit more competitive than
people think absolutely super important
date time mark your calendars October
6th 12 p.m Eastern 9 A.M Pacific time on
creations.mattel.com a simple search of
V friends you'll pull it up we have it
in our blog again October 6 12 p.m
Eastern 9 A.M Pacific time the best part
that I think is really cool as well Gary
are the series one skilled skeleton
holders they're gonna have an
opportunity to claim one for free which
is super awesome so we're really excited
for them
right well there's 40 units I don't know
I probably have a couple in My Vault but
the series one skill skeleton owners
will get this for free
absolutely so we're going to have those
details email and contacted them super
excited for them as being the OG holders
there I want to pass the mic over to
Damon and Roy if you guys just want to
introduce yourself to our community on
who you are your story what you do and
even maybe a little insight on I'm
seeing comments on who is Skeletor some
folks may just know Skeletor from the
meme which is very big in culture as
well very big so would love to hand the
mic to you guys thank you for taking the
time and we're super excited about this
partnership
uh so are we and thank you so much for
for inviting us to be a part of this um
so I am domini I am senior director
um of uh creative uh behind the design
of of the action figures of the universe
hello everyone I'm Roy Juarez and I am
the key lead packaging designer on
Masters of the Universe Origins
massavers and all these fun projects
like we're doing right now these Cloud
really excited to be here guys
amazing thank you for being on here
gentlemen what do you think from your
perspectives because you weren't there
day one but obviously you've been deep
in the Master's ecosystem with your
professions what do you think it is
about Skeletor that resonates so heavily
with people you know I grew up with
seeing the cartoon first as you know
because you're in the business but I
know because I'm a maniac about this
stuff the toys actually which was rare
for the 80s I don't remember the full
details but the cartoon was a little
delayed in comparison to the toys so
that comic book that it came with told
us about the lore the toy hit right away
even before the cartoon so I remember
vividly me and my friend Robbie turnick
Andy Greco and Eric Godfrey and Marissa
Byrd were already hyped for the first
cartoon episode of He-Man because the
toy ironically hit which was different
than Transformers GI Joe like that was
all that 80 zero where the cartoon would
come out the toy would follow
it was there was something that happened
in the history of uh He-Man Masters
Universe where the the toy actually came
out ahead of the cartoon so I was there
when cartoon one dropped and we lost our
minds but for the kids and the people
that weren't what do you think all these
years later and we're talking 40 years
what do you think it you know it is
about Skeletor even though he's the you
know we've seen this in other The Joker
we've seen this where the arch rival can
take on a life of its own but it's
Skeletor hits like on so many levels
he really doesn't again you're the
you're the master of massive man well
yeah I think I think the reason why
Skeletor resonates a lot with a lot of
the people I think it's sort of like
embracing that that evil you know like a
lot of times you know people always have
like a bad side to them but they're
always so afraid to you know show it but
I think what Skeletor just seeing it so
it kind of resonates with a lot of
people just kind of like bringing out
that bad side of you you know like the
bad boy side so
um I think that's the reason why
Skeletor does resonate with fans you
know and made the mini comics for me too
that was actually my introduction to to
He-Man you know I I grew up seeing the
cartoons no sorry not the cartoons but
the mini Comics first then I saw the
cartoon and then that was a whole
different take on it and I think it sort
of brought New Life to Skeletor just
sort of like the more comical but but
there was always that you know that evil
wanting to rule the world undertone that
always existed you know whether it be in
the mini Comics or in the um in the
cartoon so that just seems to be some
like a fun drink that he has that seems
to resonate with fans it did for me yeah
I mean he is uh evil right just no way
to to spin it in another way
um but the difference between economics
and the um and the animation was that in
the animation he became more relatable
because he there's something
um that was you saw a funny side to him
there's a comedic side in some ways
whether intentional or otherwise that
made it more relatable and he is just
cool visual on top of that you know he's
this big buff character with a skull
head so I mean you're really drawn to
him just by the cool visual
um and then depending on what Medium
you're you're reading or watching to get
into them he is a rich character there's
depth to him and and again that the
animation which you know this is this
design is based off of
um he's he's funny and relatable and and
how he uh interacts with his cast is is
I've always enjoyed that who doesn't
love the laugh right yeah
he no question he he the the dark humor
or the wink wink to the audience
watching the cartoon I mean somebody
asked when why did he become a meme or
when did he become a meme you know I
think a lot of it has to do with he had
permission to be a meme based on how he
acted in those cartoons
yeah
all right Daniel what look I know you're
going to keep us on track because I'm
already looking already 15 minutes off
the board quickly like people already
yelling at me to open the box already
they're kind of a little bit
of look at the at the brown box is this
the right time to unbox I I think it may
be time I know Damon Roy you guys also
have it as well Gary I think we should
start with you because this experience
that you're having is what folks who
purchased starting on October 6th at 12
p.m Eastern 9 A.M Pacific on Mattel's
website are gonna have this exact
unboxing experience I'm at the starting
point
find out
I like the starting oh it doesn't work
either way
um so we got the names on top okay so
here here's the right off the top gets
me super excited
is the Motu comic that comes along with
it which is humongous for me like again
like I'm gonna be very Frank here this
is like crazy
you know
it's just crazy to look at and know that
like
just a c skilled skeleton in here
is just this is bananas I don't really I
don't really have words Ginger called
out properly Robbie turning must be
going crazy the fact that this little
guy
is in I mean this is like
these comics
for me when I was 10 and 11 and 9 and
like this was huge this was the only way
we knew who the characters were at first
before the cartoon came out and
something about this just hit super
different for me like
and he-man's in there
you know it's this is a pretty big deal
yeah please as you're tapping it right
now you can just see it in your emotion
too like you're literally tapping into
like 10 year old Gary as you're seeing
this and realizing
it's been the whole journey about
building this IP you know I'm trying to
teach good virtues you know He-Man was
teaching a lot of things this was the
core of like if you really look at those
cartoons it's not only entertaining
they're teaching lessons Adam would jump
in and talk to you you know and you know
be friends has a big agenda of that and
you know I think I think that um
I think it's just crazy like you know
this really was one of the biggest IPS
for me and one of the few things I
collected I collect wrestling figures
Star Wars and He-Man was core top three
for me as a child and you know building
out this IP has just been a real
pleasure for me and did starting with
digital Collectibles and you know very
focused on that in its future obviously
nft markets where it's at right now and
so we're strategizing on what happens
going forward and you know the
collectible cards are completely out of
control with the fnatic slide thing but
collectible toys if you've been watching
my videos for years they've always been
back there right like you can go back to
any daily B and see anything in my
office they're there it's a big part
besides trading cards I had a few
minutes with comic books and I went
heavy collectible toys I have a bunch of
key man Masters of the Universe original
toys in original package that I bought
in the late 90s before this was really
like a thing thing so like you know you
know like Ramen and Mossman is still one
of the coolest characters I think ever
created in the history of creation and
as a toy bananas like we'd actually lose
it in the grass because it Blended in so
well and in the core and like you know
Beast Man and like Ramen and like
Oracle like the whole thing it's a big
IP for me and you can you can see you
know how I'm feeling about it and and
again making a limited edition
Collective I mean let's just get into it
because I'm trying to
I need to get through this
all right let's go this way first insane
just like this is this was the most
probably the most exciting part of this
for me was knowing
that for the Masters team looking
all the stuff they put out these two
gentlemen and their team it's all nasty
like it's not dorkville this is like hot
like it's real stuff like like wait do
you see the next thing this is sort of
be friends hardcore I know for people on
Instagram and others here like that
don't know be friends but this next
scene is about to kill you like this is
nuts
look at this
that's awesome
how sick is this
like this is Skeletor
literally literally teaming up with a
character that I created in my mind
and Drew
and three years later like look at look
at this like the stuff I collect the
stuff that like people flip a Comic-Con
and goes on eBay and like sits on
shelves like this is different we've
done some stuff
but like this is different like and
again what's unique about this and I
know a lot of be friends people talk
about this a lot this expands our
universe this unlike anything else we've
done this will bring Masters of the
Universe people they will collect this
and they're gonna these two gentlemen
this was huge when they explained it to
me early in the process the form factor
of Skeletor in this collectible
um we're gonna listen to them for five
minutes everyone's gonna understand why
on October 6 the competition is not
going to be the be friends Maxis it's
gonna be the friends Maxis up against
the Motu Maxis and the Skeletron Maxis
and like that's uh it's pretty exciting
so
all right I mean like that's so cool
shout out again to Roy and Damon here
because being integral in this
experience the little attention to
detail here is insane
okay all right so here we go
this is insane
oh my God this is absolutely crazy sick
look at this look at the detail oh now
I'm getting the scene look at this the
vaccine look at this literally shaking
out of excitement look at this look how
sick this packaging is this is insane
like
oh my God nice work Roy thank you Roy
this is too much brother like
so yeah just a little bit of backstory
on that packaging just wanted to um
really highlight how they each influence
each other you know so the so so we can
see from the front how um skill skeleton
influences skeletory teaches them to
embrace compassion so that's why you get
the heart-shaped hands you know coming
together and then the back side is kind
of Skeletor uh teaching skills skeleton
to embrace the Havoc side so it's kind
of like that good evil set dwelly that
we're playing with you know and um yeah
when you open up that packaging you see
that um that cool pack out there's also
like a window
um actually here you know
so when we open it right here you know
right there you can see that awesome
pack out so you got that cool
illustration you kind of like bookending
the um the product but then the um
yeah and then it has this uh removable
plastic window so then that way all the
extra piece comes in the artwork and uh
it's basically collector friendly so
you're able to just go in there get the
toys out and play with them pose them
put them back in package if you wish to
um and like I said you know like the
back side embracing The Habit F cool
close-up of skills skeleton and scale
through there and as you open that up
you get that moment there you know like
both then just kind of like arms in the
air like really feeling the power
there you go
so yeah really fun fun with this one and
then just you know fun little Doodles
here that we did on the top
collector friendly
but um yeah just cool illustrations
there we have you know
um right there sort of skilled skeleton
and um skeleton going down this hill
like on the land shark you know and then
you know also the compassion you know
just them two embracing each other
really cool moments you know there's a
lot of fun little Easter eggs throughout
just kind of cool 360 visuals all around
It's amazing And as Gary's opening it
and we're going to see something look at
this look at this
you know a couple people said the
packaging's worth it alone they're not
wrong
it's really crazy look at that
the art design here is incredible
um another cool note that I think a
couple people caught on to quickly is if
you look at skilled skeleton if you guys
put that in your room and office at
night with no lights correct me if I'm
wrong yeah but that glows in the dark he
does we absolutely want the uh we went
the route of having him glow in the dark
we thought that'd be a cool touch
something very toy attic
um and potentially in a way showing that
he's embracing the havoc and he's now
glowing with some of that that evil
Havoc energy so it's just we wanted to
have that influence of the characters
upon each other and that was one way
that how we thought we could know we can
make that happen with that skill
skeleton
it looks like Gary's trying to make his
pre-order right now on Mattel
October 6 12 p.m Eastern 9 A.M Pacific
it'll be available have you seen this
yet this is up right it's it's up you
can you can go right now to Creations
look at the zoo man no really it's
really well done like you can really
really like I'm really impressed Mattel
team
super nice Damon and Roy and even Gary
here look what are you gonna do with
them
that's awesome
how crazy is that that's my next
question it's like a skill skeleton with
Skeletor Daniel it's so crazy making the
hard hands together
it's amazing Damon what are the
accessories like kind of like the
product breakdown I think for everyone
the box is 10 out of 10 price Point's
awesome the packaging is great what's
the accessory breakdown that we have
here it's basically a two pack correct
of it is
um we're really leading into is the fact
that there's with our with our uh Master
the universe figures there's some
modularity I mean you can mix and match
some parts
um and so we wanted again to bring the
two characters together
um and have their influence and become
besties and so by creating the hard
hands you're able to Interchange some of
the hand accessories in there to create
hard hands you can create rock out hands
um or you can have hands so to encrypted
the accessories
um Skeletor has a a flex chain uh that
that the skill skeleton has given to him
that bequeathed him and he's wearing
that on the package you can see it there
on Gary screen
um he also has his Havoc step and sword
um and then there's also uh for for
Skeletor and this is this is the first
time this will be available is this is
our our new uh We've updated the bodies
of our Master the universe figures to
look more like the old animation that
we've been referencing all this time
um and so he's he stands a little taller
he's he's still very uh much a muscular
character but he's not as who we call
has that squatty body
um and the likeness of the of the uh of
his face is Overlook is based on the
animation and so you're able to mix and
match the faceplates of Skeletor so you
can have his standard look and then you
can have a look in which he's he's
feeling the the influence of of the good
that that skill skeleton has brought
into him and so that's where you see the
two different Expressions there in the
corner so you can get that I'm feeling
good kind of expression for for Skeletor
this is awesome and I'm not surprised
Gary that's
q a time oh just do some q a yeah let's
just make sure we like
yeah we oh yeah we can hear you you you
everyone good thing you didn't say
anything crazy
I can hear you is that Tyler I think
it's Tyler yeah we're gonna get into
something whatever your setting is
everyone heard you thank God
no output
nah because we're all up here so it
could only be so bad this is insane to
me uh actually before we get into q a
Damon Roy talk to everybody about why
this specific form factor of Skeletor in
action figure set
is something that most of the be friends
here unless they collect you know Motu
really won't understand
um of how big of a deal this is going to
be for the Masters community and why
this may trigger more Demand on that end
than just uh
just uh the Be Friends Community
yeah so again like I was mentioning is
this is the update so we a previous
prior to the this look for Prescott or
and for the other Master of the Universe
characters the the body has been based
off of The Styling the overall figure
was based off of the Vintage figures
um this time it's based on the on the
animation and so this is the first time
that Master of the Universe fans will be
to get their hands on
um this more filmation style look our
cartoon collection look yeah so
everybody I apologize for interrupting
brother for everybody this is why this
was such an exciting collaboration for
me knowing
that in the history of Masters of the
Universe toy collecting which is
monstrous
that the first form factor of the
animation body
is going to be available in this two
pack this becomes you know if you know
about collecting this becomes a big deal
there will be people in seven years when
they go on their Journey looking for the
first action figure that had this form
factor that will have to go and get this
toy the skilled skeleton two pack to
ever own it and that's a big big deal in
toy collecting and that will create you
know
I you know I want to use my words wisely
here because I hate to create
speculation because of everything that's
gone down in Manatee land but like let
there be no confusion this has demand in
the Masters of the Universe World in a
big way
the you know we I really feel
comfortable in Roy and his hands I mean
you know honestly you can't even imagine
how epic this really is until you have
it in your hands
and so for me as you can imagine having
an incredible amount of Focus
on how to make sure that this is
you know a worthwhile investment how do
you drive down the cost
create the excitement and expansion of
the intellectual property but create
something that has a value to people
that buy it there's only a very small
group of people on Earth that are really
going to buy this on the sixth you've
got the Be Friends Community you got the
hardcore Masters Community but like you
know this is not available at every
Walmart or Target it's not available at
every you know it's not at Comic-Con
this is directly on the website this is
going to be people in the know
unlike the Uno on collab unlike my
trading cards where it's really over
time as we build demand for we friends
those implications will happen as a
collectible this actually has a built-in
audience that I mean I've gone on the
Masters of the Universe toy and forums
and toy forums and reddits they've been
waiting for this body
Roy David people have been waiting to
know when this body comes out the fact
that it's coming out and by the way I'm
prepared for some people to be annoyed
and be like well I don't have to buy
that other skill skill like they don't
even know about people they don't care
about skill something but they're going
to want this and that creates a double
demand factor that I think is super
exciting and something I'm happy to
create for my Be Friends Community
yeah there's also one other thing that's
super cool about this figure that um
that hasn't been done before and if you
can see like there's basically these two
face plates that you care for Skeletor
so the head is actually the faceplate's
swappable you can actually remove the
face plate and then put these other
different to the different Expressions
on him so that we haven't done that yet
in Origins that'll be the first time
that we're actually doing that in this
form factor so that's actually super
cool something really cool also yeah
Daniel are we a lot of people are asking
about quantity are we
that's not that's not public information
almost fell off his arm
hold on I got a handful
[Music]
like go ahead one important thing to
note again October 6 12 p.m Eastern 9
A.M Pacific 45 dollars three per
customer we have a limit there's a limit
here so something to be aware of that I
think is super important as we're
talking about quantity is there is a
limit of three per customer so just high
level that's super important but
um we got some folks on the backstage
Gary and Damon Roy if you guys are ready
for some q a you see a bunch of other
people the affordability like this is
something I was blown away that that
Mattel was able to come through on like
I do a lot of I've done a lot of toy
collecting I don't know how to tell you
like 45 for what they did you know it's
funny 25 bucks a lot of money I don't
think of that as like no money but it's
funny watching the chat as I was talking
there's enough people that are educated
that were like the boxes were like like
there's people like people that are you
know they say the website says 50. maybe
that's because they have an updated it's
updated it could be a hard refresh thing
we're good hard refresh Mikey toy box
um you know I appreciate Mikey's all out
on this like and this is a big shout out
to Mattel and and y'all I can't believe
what you packed in here for the price
thank you really thank you
that's awesome and yeah again two packs
so it's two characters the glow in the
dark the accessories the boxing the mini
comic strip all of it just super well
done guys I love it thank you thank you
awesome let's go ahead and get some q a
I know we got some people waiting up
there if you guys are game
um backstage if you guys want to bring
some some folks up I know they're really
excited Roy Damon were you guys about to
say something or no we're just seeing
how much fun we had uh working on this
and working with the the befriends team
it's been it's been a pleasure it's been
it's a lot of fun
thank you brother look at this
Robbie Clark what's up brother
hey what's up brother first congrats
this is amazing we're a similar age like
this was my childhood and another toy
from a different brand but I mean
Masters of the Universe big deal so I'm
pumped for you man that's so cool
I appreciate Chris Boyd coming in heavy
go ahead rob you have a question for
these guys yeah so so these guys and for
you as well Gary like collaborations
obviously big deal V friends for the
next for your lifetime but like
business-wise like for you what's
important about how you collab who you
collab with is there just some like you
know askgaryvee advice on how to do
collabs properly
you know I think you have to have intent
and truth you know
um I I don't mind mentioning other IPS
and find these guys Rob so like
Thundercats I like ThunderCats
I you know I like them but there was a
humongous Delta you're talking if Star
Wars and wrestling were 10 for me He-Man
was nine and Thundercats was four
and so if I'm able to have a
collaboration with He-Man first
authenticity right I can speak about
Mossman in detail I can talk about man
like I can talk about you know Sheila
like I could talk about stuff I remember
you know like I remember when it's when
Shiro was launched I remember AJ AJ I'm
sorry to blow up your spot but I
remember my four-year-old brother
sitting in the living room saying I am
Shira like obviously you love you know
as an older brother I love just saying
that out loud to the world so everyone
can joke with AJ about it
um
battle cat and snake mountain and the
lessons from Adam and like it's an
authentic so first I love authenticity
right like I love that I can speak to
this it means something to me as a
matter of fact I don't know if it was
I'm sure it was caught on film I'm sure
some of you saw this we've announced a
lot of things through the years I got a
little bit emotional there as I was
going through I was even shaking my
hands were shaking a little that's
unheard of I'm like like I never shake
like this means a lot to me so that
matters with collaboration I think it
needs to mean something but then there's
also the business factor of it I know
that this is going to acquire more
awareness because I know how sought
after this skeletal you know we talked
through this and these guys know like
there was a lot of conversations here
there was times where I was like I'm not
sure I want to do this because I want to
be right I want to be a great partner
too
I want to sell through like you know
there's a lot that goes into this and
again you know this I see Mo just joined
you know he's been following Chris like
it's a journey this is a true journey
and knowing how this IP started it'd be
like an IP that started with like a
canceled cartoon after one season like
you know we've had the ups and downs of
the nft market a core part of this the
trading cards thing is bro I'm like I'm
really pot committed long term to this
and so I have to think about things that
make strategy and then and then honestly
I care about the collectible aspect of
all this like this is a very highly
collectible piece at an obnoxiously
affordable price
and so I'm excited about that for the
people that you know Rob I get it like
50 to 75 of people are going to want to
buy one and put on their shelf but you
know we thought through a lot about the
three product limit and I thought
through like what does that mean and
like
you know like we think through this
stuff and like I know if people buy
three they're thinking about let me own
one maybe I'll flip two and I worry
about it being up or down like you know
like I'm not in control of when people
decide to flip it or trade or things so
you just think about all these things
but you know I think for me
um I think there's an enormous amount of
credibility that comes to the IP in in
having someone like Masters of the
Universe even be interested in
collaborating elevates skill skeleton
I'm thinking about storytelling there's
a lot in the pipe around animation music
content you know this creates a context
Point
um you know there's a lot of there's a
lot of uh
a lot of things to think about you know
uh three is not just there because I
think most people actually I think more
people are buying three to give two of
these as a gift because a lot of the
fans of this IP sit in their 30s 40s and
50s
right so I know for sure if I was one of
the three of you that are on screen
right now like I'm buying one for Robbie
turnick and buying one for Eric Godfrey
for Father's Day you know like because I
want you know because think about it a
lot of you are emotionally attached to
this IP oh I'm gonna give one to you
know my friend because it's a nice gift
he or she will be pumped about Skeletor
but it's going to make them introduce
them to be friends and so just a lot of
thoughts that go into my man price point
you know about like this one
one of the big triggers you know you
know this a lot of things we do with
Partners they don't have an
international structure one of the
things we've been spending more and more
time on is what do we say yes and no to
if they don't have international
infrastructure you know I want to make
sure this is available in Canada if
let's say A very handsome man with good
hair would want to buy it in Canada and
so like you know you got to be ready for
all these things so we think about it
and there's all like twists and turns we
were in a meeting for an hour and a half
about a bunch of stuff you're all about
to hear in the next two three weeks
you're just making lots of decisions
lots of decisions on the tone the
temperature you know this has been a
long time in the making oh well over a
year they're trying to anticipate those
things like what's the world look like
in a year so a lot of things brother so
for you so much when I saw the willful
wizard I thought of Orco
right so for you like when I'm trying to
like you know push on to like Reebok
about this or that I'm trying to when I
forward it to their CEO and say you
something with my man here I'm trying to
think about what you could actually
bring to the table so there's a lot you
know there's a lot Chris here
thanks so much Rob I appreciate it we
have Chris up here yep I can hear you as
well we have Mohit is Mohit as well
thank you guys and Chris one second here
I know we have the mask on I'm actually
gonna hand the mic really quick over to
Mohit only because Gary what crazy thing
we did prioritization with this tool we
can actually give access to spectacular
so Mohit eat it Chris eat it
I mean Chris to eat it
oh
it's sex getting some love
um
price point Gary I think you up
it's not a 45 product it has to be a lot
higher because I have a seven-year-old
kid and I go buy toys and 45 doesn't buy
you much these days yeah yeah but anyhow
you know I I forgive you there's a
couple ways to think about that I think
to your answer if I up there's a
lot of reality of that being on the
consumer Shelf
I I do think I do think and we do think
a lot and we're feeling it with super
sticker pricing and some other stuff are
we in a place where we want to maximize
every dollar
on suggested retail
right or do we want to leave some room
for think about how small who's going to
get this is and so I'm I'm very
empathetic to your point and I think
from a one business angle your
aggressive call out of like you
up is right I think from a different
angle of leaving dollars on the table
for the audience that first owns it is
another fun way to debate it and a big
call out you know somebody in there Mo
said oh 45 utility for getting a free
one for a skill right we're playing
forever and so as you can imagine even
like we just talked through a bunch of
burnt Islands some of them are this
narrow some of them are this wide one of
the things I'm trying to think through
is like not like everyone in a silo can
be analyzed but a collective over 20 40
50 70 activations I'm trying to think of
the Ebbs and flows and like leave
different rooms for different things so
uh I respect that point of view and I I
think hey there's more on the IEP uh
building standpoint
um so if you look at skilled skeleton as
a character this is the first activation
it's been featured in Halloween what
does the journey look like do you do you
plan on getting skilled skeleton in
another collab with let's say a
completely different you know from you
know what I mean yeah like a great
question what I'm worried about is
it can get to a point where skill
skeleton has had I know let's say 11
activations in four years and now the
journey feels a little lost yeah
yeah you know but like there's two
separate tracks here one I used you this
era as Alpha right you go look at
Daredevil
episode first appearance he's in full
yellow it's got a different personality
today we don't see them that way so I I
will say officially and I haven't really
said I've alluded to it but I'm very
comfortableness I do Leave myself and my
team the creative freedom to adjust
narratives personalities things that
nature I'm going through that very
heavily right now
that being said
great call out about brand integrity and
how you build I don't think it's going
to be 11. you know we're not we're not
in that place where we're gonna create
so many mixed messages that by the time
we kind of solidify obviously we're very
aggressively and I think we're finally
getting to the point where the community
will start to see this there's been
incredible work on character development
we've got kids book coming out next year
animation and content is a very big part
of next year and so I think you're going
to start seeing some characters solidify
themselves and to your point MO
you're going to see some of your
favorite characters show up next year in
animation form and it might be different
than the little cartoons or even the
social media content from a personality
from a voice from A vibe at the same
time because we're in Alpha but but as
we now are kind of getting into the
fourth year third year things that
nature some of these characters are
going to mold in so to your point I
don't think you'll see skilled skeleton
and six more things that are completely
dispersed and then there's confusion
that's what I was with yeah and I think
I think that's a very good call I don't
think you'll see that I think we're
starting to Zone in
um on certain characters doing certain
things and so
it's a mix to your question there is
definitely some Alpha going on I've not
been scared to put out a mini video on
social or part of the toy thing and then
if I change my mind on gratitude
gorillas or Genuine like I still think
we're quote-unquote early enough at the
same token I'm incredibly conscious of
if we do too many things too many times
with the same characters there's so much
confusion it might take mockery to
solidify
okay and you said the animation thing is
getting closer I mean I know that's
something we're all very excited about
is that happening
as you can imagine there's been a lot of
thoughtfulness
oh sorry somebody might need to go mute
um it's uh not only the thoughtfulness
of the proper way to do it proper proper
the process of Animation is quite an
interesting long journey like
um I remember going into a meeting early
on and said I wanna I want a Halloween
special and they're like three years I'm
like what you know it's so um you know
animation's a beast but we yeah I've
mentioned about the animation business
my wife started I think a few months ago
we you know real quick I mean you know
for people on YouTube it's called out of
a book but I am
I'm realizing that like I tell my voice
over artist we need to change something
and when she does change that that
doesn't show up on the video for like
six months and we are like nothing and
we're like tiny you know you know that's
why South Park is so brilliant and we've
we've got a lot of different tweaks so
look we're gonna play high low left
right with animation we'll see a lot
more in the future Mo thank you brother
thank you thank you excited
Chris thank you for being patient I love
that your dresser for the occasion any
questions you have while we have Damon
and Roy here as well for the Mattel team
on the product I know you're super into
it right now and as a iconic Soldier I
see you
I appreciate that um yes my question is
to anybody who wants to answer but um
what is your favorite part during this
collaboration process and maybe talk
about some challenges that you may have
had during the process I'm always I love
the process of how these things come
together
um so yeah take it away yeah let's do
this boy Damon let me make you feel very
comfortable I know we know each other a
little bit but like one of the things I
love is vulnerability transparency like
like you know I'm also probably very
comfortable with this question because I
know how I treat collaborations so I
don't think it could be too horrible
whatever comes out of your mouth
um I think it you know why don't you
answer Chris's answer in twofold one
this collaboration and two maybe the
others that you've done or considered
and what the variable differences are or
some of the common themes for people
that are thinking about it
so the the fun part of the about the
collaboration is basically when you have
the other team coming with their idea to
the table and you know just kind of
hearing them out seeing what they like
or you know what they don't like and
just kind of taking that and then also
working here with our internal team and
then just kind of blending the two ideas
that's that part's always the fun part
because you're basically
you know you're trying to you're kind of
like kind of the way you're kind of like
the middle person trying to make you
know this side happy this and happy and
just bringing the two ideas meshing them
together and that part's fun
um and that's also kind of like the the
challenge too because sometimes some
ideas can be very different right
Sometimes some team might have something
very different and then you're kind of
seeing your perspective from like your
own IP and then you're seeing and then
they're seeing it from their own IP so
that can be a a challenging part but but
again you know just bringing the two
ideas together that's always like the
fun part that I have for me it's about
the story what is the story we're
telling why are we bringing these two
Brands together
um how are they interacting you know
what what is that Nexus what is that the
Confluence of of their of those
personalities and the worlds
um and once we struck that idea of of
having skill skeleton and skeletal or
you haven't influence on each other
that this is the first time we drew
Skeletor with this
hilarity ensued and we're like okay we
found it this is it
and we were super stoked because it was
we had to find that touch Point um and
once we did it was it was almost easy at
that point
and for me Chris you have to know you
have to know the role you play so for me
when I go into this partnership for
example
I'm aware of the 40 Years of Rich
history
I sometimes I have to do my homework
whether that's like squishmallow right I
did 20 hours of community homework
before I went into that collab because I
wanted to get a sense this one was easy
for me my friends who are actual friends
and acquaintances who are hardcore you
know Masters collectors right so for me
it was about and I I hope these two guys
can tell you how incredibly quote
unquote hands off I was you know I have
a young IP I have a lot of freedom they
have an incredibly mature important IP
they have less Freedom they have to hold
up so many values so many history
lessons so many things that the
community holds cherish and important
and so for me it was about flexibility
and really giving them creative freedom
at the highest levels of course there'd
be things that I wouldn't compromise
like I couldn't have the comic you know
the Masters comic kill skill skeleton
that'd be bad I have things to do with
skills you know but but in this scenario
and this is something I've noticed Chris
a lot of people come to me and they want
to collab in all forms of life where I
have all the leverage and they come in
with audacity
and I smile to myself I'm like you're
the one asking
you know you know even though we had an
incredible Uno collaboration and even
though I have an incredible relationship
with you know Mass uh with Mattel it
wasn't like these two emailed me 55
times and said we need to do a collab
you know I was coming with the idea
quote unquote the ask and so I think too
many people
don't have the humility
when and understanding the roles and to
me I knew how to hold up
the Skeletor and O2 IP and I wasn't
willing to draw lines in the sand other
than I wanted these two gentlemen in the
team to feel incredibly authentic and
was willing
to go through a lot of work and meetings
with my team and them and if they were
unable to get to an authentic place I
was mentally I told my team I said
listen this could be 15 20 meetings this
could be hundreds of hours of collective
work and they may have to come to us at
11 30 p.m before midnight and say we
don't feel it and so like I think that's
you know something to keep in mind
around collaborations you know
cool thank you very much that was
awesome thanks so much Chris we got two
more coming up on stage as well
um Damon Roy and even Gary how rare is
it to see Skeletor in that vein with
like the hearts and actually having a
smile like is that super rare like for
folks that don't know anything about
Skeletor like this seems kind of unique
in that way never been done before all
right it's something very very very
unique I mean there he has had
expression changes in in different
content but to have it in product and to
do something that's very modern and
contemporary is is a little break frame
um but again it made sense because a
story it made sense because of the
collaboration
um and the influence of one another and
so that's why we brought it together so
like yeah it's it's first time and and
it it has to make sense in this this
made sense that's amazing hearing the
the line never been done before and then
having Masters of the Universe and be
friends in that sentence is pretty
remarkable for this character it goes
back to Chris's last question should
have like look I really as you can
imagine one to me compassion respect
respect new collaborations like the way
you enter someone's home
when I tell you when I enter someone's
home and it is obvious in the first
nanosecond that I have to take my shoes
off I'm taking my shoes off I'm entering
someone's home
I don't care what my point of view on
that is I can do anything I want in my
home if I smell it in the first Nano
second my shoes are coming off
immediately I'm respecting entering
someone's home so first this is a
40-year home 50-year home like it's a
real home at you know Motu but as you
can imagine Daniel in return once we got
over that
I knew that I wanted to do great things
for
be friends
I have responsibility for this community
and so you're hearing the first first
form factor first first like I know how
much this is going to bring demand for
this collectible this toy and that's
going to be of the benefit of the people
in our community and I want that that's
awesome well we got two spectacular
people here on stage with us I'm gonna
hand it to gag on first just because you
did have the the hand up and we'll pass
it over to Laura if you guys have a
question for Garrett even the Mattel
team while we have them super awesome
sure uh thanks Daniel can you guys hear
me yeah we hear you yeah hey a question
for Gary first of all great work
everybody and I think in the industry of
authenticity uh my only exposure to the
character is through memes yeah coming
out right up front yeah and uh and also
I just have to say looking back the box
is the most badass interpretation of the
different character I've ever seen so
far uh fingers crossed uh so so that's
on the creative side
yeah like it's just it's a super cool uh
my question specifically was I think and
you've been talking about this since the
pre-mint days right expanding the IP
which is more sort of creative side of
things and we also talk about left and
right frame right so on the Quant side
like how do you quantify these
collaborations right like how do you
really measure the success like six
months 12 months on the line and so on
that so already with trading cards I I
can see first-time buyers of different
Series 2 nfts record correlated to
accounts that are on social that we can
backtrack into their social and see that
they discovered the IP at the national
so there's a lot of work we do to see
what brings people into consideration to
the nft
and so we think especially during this
Market
physical Collectibles is an incredible
way to do it I think you're going to see
it quite a bit
you know when I when I heard you just
say that you don't understand how good
that made me feel about your exposure to
Skeletor my dream is that you go to a
streaming service or on or YouTube and
now watch an episode like you can't
imagine how epic skeletorious and for me
I know I personally and the Be Friends
Community brings a big audience I mean
motu's humongous but we're not tiny tiny
there's gonna be a real chunk here and
I'm pumped that so many people from be
friends will now maybe consider Motu as
something they care about and in return
the way I'll measure this in a couple
ways one did this bring value to my
audience both for they're happy
little things like you saying this is
the most badass interpretation of the
character I'm excited about that I have
a lot of badass intentions maybe some
could call it bad intentions
um but
we haven't shown that yet right we've
shown you where series two is which is a
little bit of a different thing and got
a kids book coming out so showing a
little bit of the preview
to I want people in Motu to fall in love
with be friends as well and I know
through this in I can't wait to go to
San Diego Comic-Con next year
and walk around and see this at
collector's tables for sale and say
hello to them be like oh and they're
like oh and they they may be a collector
that's not even thinking about be
friends all they cared about was you
know the part we talked about earlier
which is how important in Masters this
this figure is
right but by just being a Comic-Con my
ability to be like hey and learn and so
in a long-term view we're looking at how
much did this
bring people into the franchise but the
other thing is does this now create the
framework of where this character can
play obviously we won't have the luxury
of it playing
in the Masters universe but like what
the energy of this collaboration allows
for the truth like think about a skilled
skeleton
reference to this collaboration in five
years
think about a skill skeleton video game
or cartoon or book
that has skilled skeleton dreaming
something from a scene from this comic
and it's like a little you know Easter
egg there's just so many things that can
be done so we're establishing permission
and consideration
awesome
thank you so much guy appreciate you I'm
going to hand the mic over to Laura and
Laura just a quick shout out on a person
on a everyone knows you're a creative a
copywriter I just want to congratulate
you Gary I don't know if you know Laura
just recently released a new book called
duck buddies which is really awesome
just want to give her her flowers it's
not easy as you know as an operator
creatively to launch something like that
so yeah thank you Daniel at Sicily and
thanks to you Gary too you signed a a
rough draft copy at vcon and he wrote
keep crushing I remember and I just keep
that because you know everyone
encounters ups and downs as you create
something so I always kept that in my
mind oh my gosh you just so you
understand like be friends are the only
ones in the chat but people could be
also watching this on my socials because
I wanted to make sure it's on Instagram
again a big part of my requirement is
access to the be friends holders but
awareness to the broader section so more
people become those people all right
Laura go ahead this is so cool and I'm
an 80s baby too so this is really
exciting
like how sick
how sick and the detail I'm telling you
it's nuts thing we didn't go into the
they talked about it for a second but
the hands switch out it's like it's a
wild toy like I I think most point is
absolutely right the price point is
remarkable yeah my younger brother and I
watched all these cartoons all the time
so my question for Dame and Roy and you
Gary is what are maybe some metrics or
general things you're trying to hit to
kind of test this as a great collab and
would you potentially do other
characters like He-Man and Shira in the
future depending
I'll let Allah Mattel you know Motu team
answer from their perspective person
I think you kind of hit on some of that
already Gary is it what is what is the
the fan of resonance how are they
reacting how are they from from both
sides of of be friends and Motu how are
they seeing the value in this and
they're are they in are they enjoying
the story that we're telling do they
want to see more and and these are the
things that we would be considering
because yeah great to bring in uh more
more characters from be friends and more
characters remotes and bring them
together in this type of ways like we
really enjoyed uh
look Shiro was very top of mind I told
you my story like that is one of my
greatest memories in my childhood was my
brother when we first moved to Hunterdon
County New Jersey we didn't have cable
at first
and like literally all we had was like
Shira on tape and it was playing over
and over and over because AJ was three
four and that was his favorite cartoon
AJ was Shira for a full year
AJ with Shira and so you know look I
look the Uno collaboration if the Uno
collaboration did not go so great for
Mattel we're not here today right right
now I anticipate because of how
passionate Masters of the Universe you
know and and they know there's some
purists who are gonna be like what the
like you can't have anybody from
the outside the question becomes what we
just saw earlier I also know that for
that small group
right that there's a wider group of tens
of thousands of people in our world that
are going to re fall in love with this
character this IP Discover it I have a
very young crew as well not just the 30
40 50. many have only known this guy
from uh a meme this now gives him
another story they read the comic so you
know hopefully this goes well and
hopefully there's opportunities I mean
Fearless fairy and Shira is a nice
little two pack right you know there's a
lot to be done but we don't want to rush
it or force it either and so yeah
there's definitely things to Think
Through
cool thank you guys thank you Laura we
got last two questions here rapid fires
we hit Top of the hour yeah I have a
three o'clock hard so I'll go for sure
Danny good to see you yeah real quick I
was like seven years old when this came
out I don't really remember all the
story details um of Masters of universe
but I am excited I saw that you can get
it on Apple and you can go watch them
again do you guys still create new new
like
animations and and new like story lines
with He-Man and Skeletor
yes yes so if you if you have a Netflix
account you can watch uh some great
content there so we have new animation
um new season starting in the spring uh
so if you have more to come
and then the other thing for Gary and
the collab team
what's the what's the process on like
sneaking in
um skilled skeleton into like an
animation like that you guys have to get
permission from Gary does Gary up to
like want it like how does all that work
anybody who owns any IP controls that IP
and so there's no sneaking especially
I get what you're saying from some of
the purest like if Skeletor was like
this evil like bad guy right like they
might not like the heart and the soft
side of you know yeah that's right
there's always those kind of things but
you keep pushing the envelope and you
keep trying to figure it out and that
becomes the game love you Benny good to
see you let's get into it yes because I
got it Anthony's 60 seconds here on the
clock good to see you
uh go ahead
oh wait let's see if anybody can unmute
him let's see if he can looks for Google
all right so the whole kindest thing why
Gary now like does this kindness thing
really work for Mattel in a sense with
this character and will there be other
avenues with the other refunds
characters
no I can't speak for Mattel I can tell
you that back to the same way they
couldn't compromise on anything
you know like I'm not going to
compromise that kindness is the greatest
skill that I want to teach in the world
and so I'm thrilled that it worked for
Mattel and I think Skeletor does have a
really irreverent personality and you to
be very honest I think about why someone
would say yes the reason I get a lot of
deals done is I give a lot of thought to
even the potential of a yes from the
other side and I know way way way too
much about Skeletor to know that this is
absolutely in Pocket to play because
it's absolutely the curveball that
Skeletor can throw
um and so you know I I can't speak for
Mattel obviously they've spoken with the
decision to make
um but I think we all think about like
what's important and for me like skill
skeletons showing up in Snake Mountain
and then just trying to beat up He-Man
you know or Ram it like like that wasn't
gonna work that wasn't gonna get the
full story across of what we need to get
done
I was psyched to see the shorts on
JetBlue so keep up the good work man
thank you but yeah the JetBlue shorts is
fun and like it's gonna be a really a
really fun October's
let me end with Damon Roy thank you I
love you men thank you you're so excited
everybody else who's watching anywhere
all all my social right now is linked to
the current blog post I'll link it again
lots of will be very loud over the next
week or two about the launch October 6th
on this and October is loud I'm also
live on fnatics live tomorrow night
doing more pack breaking so please go to
be friends coffee befriends.com cards
make sure you follow the befriends cards
account specifically on X Twitter
there's information there register your
Fanatics live
um account because tomorrow's gonna be a
big night of giveaways because I'm in
the mood so we'll see you soon love you
all bye thank you everyone
right thank you Gary thank you Anthony
closing out here everyone reminder
October 6 12 p.m Eastern 9 A.M Pacific
this is going to be on Mattel's website
This Is Us International Super insane
Damon Roy thank you so much again any
final words here as we close out for the
community the coolest
there it is thank you everyone thank you
thank you thank you it's been a blast
thank you everyone